Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Seven: the Realm Community, and Greenland.
Denmark is in a realm community, rigsfællesskab, with Greenland and the Faroe Islands.
The official name for this realm community is "Kongeriget Danmark", the Kingdom of Denmark.
The constitution applies to all three parts of Denmark's realm, which has the king as head of state.
The Faroe Islands and Greenland each elect two members to the Folketing.
Greenland and the Faroe Islands pass their own laws in a long list of areas and have their own administration.
In the other areas, the Folketing passes the laws also for Greenland and the Faroe Islands, and the administration lies with the Danish authorities.
This applies, among other things, to foreign and security policy and to currency and monetary policy.
In 2005, Greenland and the Faroe Islands got the possibility, each separately or together, to negotiate and enter into certain international agreements on behalf of the realm.
Now, Greenland.
Greenland's geography.
Greenland, with 2.1 million square kilometres, is the world's largest island.
It is about as big as Germany, France, the United Kingdom, Spain, Italy and Greece together.
Greenland is geographically part of the North American continent and lies far to the north, northeast of Canada.
Greenland's area makes up 98 percent of the area of the entire realm community, Denmark, Greenland and the Faroe Islands.
About 83 percent of Greenland is covered by ice all year.
The biggest continuous area is called the Inland Ice, Indlandsisen.
It covers 1.7 million square kilometres, or about 80 percent of Greenland's total area, and is up to 3,400 metres thick.
Greenland's highest point is Gunnbjørn Fjeld, which lies in East Greenland, 3,694 metres above sea level.
Gunnbjørn Fjeld is by the way also the world's highest point north of the Arctic Circle.
The roughly 57,000 inhabitants live along the coast.
About 20,000 live in the capital Nuuk, also called Godthåb, which is Greenland's largest town.
Greenland's history.
Greenland has been inhabited for millennia.
From about the year 2500 before Christ, smaller groups of Arctic hunter peoples immigrated in several rounds from Canada.
Greenland's north, west and east coasts were all populated, and different hunter cultures arose.
Finds of, among other things, animal bones show that the northern cultures were dependent on musk ox hunting, while the southern cultures lived on seal hunting and reindeer hunting.
Today's Greenlandic people, the Inuit, immigrated from Alaska and Canada around the year 1200 after Christ to north-western Greenland and later spread to South Greenland.
Archaeological finds show that Icelanders and Norwegians already in the 900s after Christ settled in Greenland.
These so-called Norse people joined in the 1200s the Norwegian king and thereby followed into the Danish-Norwegian union from 1380.
After that they disappeared from Greenland during the 1400s.
Possibly also because climate changes with a colder climate as a result made it difficult to farm in Greenland.
In the 1500s and 1600s, the Danish king sent a series of expeditions, but a permanent Danish presence in Greenland only took root in the 1700s.
In 1721, the priest Hans Egede travelled to the island to find the Norse people again.
When he did not find the Norse people, he settled to trade and make the Inuit Christian, and in 1728 he founded the colony Godthåb, which today is the capital of Greenland, in Greenlandic Nuuk.
To promote the spread of Christianity in Greenland, Hans Egede also founded the Greenlandic written language, so that he could write down and publish texts from the Bible in the Greenlanders' own language.
This early spread of the Inuit language in writing has had great importance for the language today being better preserved in Greenland than among the Inuit populations in Canada and Alaska.
During the 1700s and 1800s, Denmark set up several colonies in Greenland, from which Greenlandic products were traded that were sold in Europe.
This applied especially to blubber, fat, from seals and whales, which could be boiled into train oil, tran, an oil that was used for lighting.
With the spread of electric lamps at the beginning of the 1900s, fishing became instead Greenland's most important industry.
From 1776 to 1950, a state company, the Royal Greenland Trading Department, Den Kongelige Grønlandske Handel, had a monopoly, exclusive right, on all trade in Greenland and also administered the Greenlandic colonies.
That meant the Greenlanders were only allowed to sell their goods to the Danish colony managers, who thereby secured control of the trade.
Conversely, the Royal Danish Greenland Trade also had a duty to supply the small Greenlandic settlements with goods from outside, for example flour, groats, salt, sugar, knives, hunting weapons and cotton clothes.
Greenland was in this period also a closed country for foreigners.
Only persons with a special permit and task from the Danish state, for example as civil servants, craftsmen, doctors or priests, had access.
During the Second World War, Greenland, unlike Denmark, was not occupied by the Germans.
In violation of the German occupying power's, and thereby also the Danish government's, wishes, Denmark's ambassador in Washington DC, Henrik Kauffmann, in 1941 entered into an agreement with the USA which gave the Americans permission to set up military bases in Greenland.
That was necessary, among other things, to protect and supply the inhabitants of Greenland with foodstuffs, building materials, medicine and fuel, which they had until then got from Denmark.
The Americans wanted conversely to prevent other countries, especially Germany, occupying Greenland, and in addition the USA was to use minerals from Greenland's subsoil for its war production.
After the Second World War, the USA continued to have military bases in Greenland by agreement with Denmark.
At the beginning of the 1950s, the Americans built a base in Qaanaaq, Thule, in North Greenland, whereby the settlement of several Greenlandic families was moved to make room for the base.
The base is the USA's northernmost military base, and there was only a short distance to the Soviet Union, and therefore it was central to the air defence of the USA and NATO.
Earlier the base has been known as Thule Air Base or the Thule Base.
In 2023, it was renamed Pituffik Space Base, and it is still used by the USA.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which island group is part of the Danish Realm Community?
Option A: The Shetland Islands.
Option B: The Orkney Islands.
Option C: The Faroe Islands.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende øgrupper er en del af det danske rigsfællesskab?  A: Shetlandsøerne  |  B: Orkneyøerne  |  C: Færøerne
The answer is C: The Faroe Islands.
It appeared in the June 2020 and June 2021 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Færøerne
Question 2.
Where does the USA have the Thule air base?
Option A: On Bornholm.
Option B: In the Faroe Islands.
Option C: In Greenland.
[DA] Hvor har USA luftbasen Thulebasen?  A: På Bornholm  |  B: På Færøerne  |  C: I Grønland
The answer is C: In Greenland.
It appeared in the November 2021 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: I Grønland
Question 3.
What is Greenland's largest town called?
Option A: Nuuk.
Option B: Tórshavn.
Option C: Reykjavik.
[DA] Hvad hedder Grønlands største by?  A: Nuuk  |  B: Tórshavn  |  C: Reykjavik
The answer is A: Nuuk.
It appeared in the May 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Nuuk
Question 4.
How large a share of Greenland is covered by ice all year?
Option A: About 40 percent.
Option B: About 60 percent.
Option C: About 80 percent.
[DA] Hvor stor en andel af Grønland er dækket af is hele året?  A: Cirka 40 procent  |  B: Cirka 60 procent  |  C: Cirka 80 procent
The answer is C: About 80 percent.
It appeared in the November 2023 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Cirka 80 procent
Question 5.
Does the constitution apply in the Faroe Islands and Greenland?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Gælder grundloven på Færøerne og i Grønland?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the May 2024 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
That's the end of Part One of Episode 7.
In Part Two, we continue with Greenland's self-government, economy and culture.
See you there.